ええええええ
20分
ません
決断という言葉を聞いてい
皆さんはパス何を思い浮かべますか
かの有名な
君白のオシャレ負けないものを
こんな言葉を残しています
決断力から中立に逃げる者はトロッ
激しいいや厳しい表現でしまっ
これはフィレ次ぎ多くの外交官という性質のでおそらく自分自身の決断はずに
銀コンペティション存亡がかかっているなんていうことを考えていたから
こんな激しい人気になっているかもしれません
まだからに限らず9搭載の英雄維新は決算に関する多くの名言格言を残しています
それほど決断というのは僕らの人生において重要なピースであることがわかります
そして現在生きる僕らぶっ
彼ら栄養決断とは程度の差こそあれ
毎日が決断の連続です
過去に行った過去にを下した自分の決断ひとつが今の号クラブ
そして未来の僕らを形作ってということはいえばではありません
未来を突き詰めて考えれば
まだ訪れていない
すべての瞬間ます
その偽ライダーなぜ投票か
なぜ重要なのかと問われれば僕はこう答えます
それはまだ訪れていないからではなく
短波一人を決断によってイモトは全く新しい世界の話になっているからです
たとえ誰も自動車だって欲しがらないよ
だっていうのはすごいみんなが馬に慣れてるし
馬の餌となる草外ラージュに入っ
そして1本が遊びなどがあるがそういう男にも前だから来るまで作っても売れないよう
になんてことを
格好の人本気で言っていたんです
今どうでしょう馬車道ば社長ってますかね
という風に
この時否定され車でいいじゃない
そんなことを言われていた人が今僕らの歓声会が来ると新3
決断し諦めるではなくやり続けようという決断を下したからこそ今の世界はあります
このようなん
僕は決断とは難しい荒野と思っています
阿含
今までこんなに頑張ってきたんだから
ここだけ止めたらもったいない
今までこんなに頑張ってきたのに成果が出ないからやめろ
なようなことはシーンを違う皆さん
経験されていると思います
このようなシーンに直面した場合皆様どうながら決断を下しますか
そしてその決断を下す基準と一体どんなかなものなんですよ
今日
僕の経験が巧いやり続けるべきなのか
諦めるべきだろう決断フラスーツな継続か絶対かの決断について話したいと思います
宜しくお願いします
申し遅れましたて僕の名前はしだとバレています
こちらは山菜は僕です
祭りの法被を着てるんですけど本当は広まらないくらい可愛い
自分と思うんです
僕はぜひ発見してますね愛してに言われました
そして a
横浜国立大学に入学生様に上京しました
ん
大学でてか
平素からのリーダーシップ経理のという
五百蔵恭順対抗されている ceo に感銘を受け起業を志しましたん
そしてブロックチェーンデー
ブログチェーンは広く普及して当たり前のように使われるようになる
それは確定した未来で出題するないことだと僕は勝4
地蔵一番いいブロックチェーンを聞いてパッチをつける a 正明さんという現場に
大破します
そして歳です
東京大学6ch 学生休暇支援プログラムという東西のアクセラレーションプログラム
に選出していただきましたーーー
ああああああ
[拍手]
デコながらが曲全てを僕は持ってきたんですけど
その中でやっぱり一番痛感することがあっ
いやり続けるか諦めパンケーキパンしかしいうことです
パワー分野を壊す
成功の角度されているをやり続ける力だったりやり抜く力
グリッドという言葉と思いますまさに水 nest がベストセラーだっているあの本
が示している通りです
そして
その恐怖をやり続けるという言葉を本当に美しい言葉です
自分がうまくいっている時が人生の興味を起こされていないん
などまさにこの言葉や理念としからその言葉の氷だと思う
は絶対最後にがんばるぞ
決心満ち溢れています
ただ一方でこのやり抜くという言葉をとても残酷な言葉でもあります
自分が人生の基本だろさ
迷っているうまくいっていないときは
とても残酷な言葉になっています
高いはもし自分の友人はとても努力していたのでうまくいっていない
それはたとえやり抜くこと大正解だったとしても
まやりずっとべきであるとなかなか言いにくいです
もしそれが本当にステイタイの書いてあったとしてください今ならもう
ここまで頑張ったんだから
q フェイシャルんじゃないかなんかことを伝えたくなります
これもや利益という言葉は難しいです二面性があります
まあ方法もまさしくこのような状態がありました
それは僕のジャパンフィスター cm の remember 乗り出すように
今回思想に当たってです
巨大も3月黒子は大きな問題を抱えていました
今みたいにアクセラーに選ばれない取材依頼が期待でき大企業と手を組んでいろいろ
ノート進めている紹介がありませんです
全く成果はできませんでしたし
どこに行っても誰に話してもノーだとこの一言を言われました
ん
早く帰ってくるみたいな感じで追い出されたことがありました
しかし僕はそんな否定規定の連続でも本自身とか分る新年だからこそやり続ければ出て
いました
しかし新メンバーの一人はそんな否定に生の列に支えられたになっていたかと
僕の co の坂もの自分自身のことでいっぱいれ
彼を気遣う余裕はありませんでした
そんなのに彼ら電話がかかっ
俺ジャパンフェスで止めないん
僕はこの子も t シャツにも赤のが混乱してしまって
行ったら降ってるんだあ日本語で話されているんですよ
日本語じゃないようになります
そらーん
スタートアップとはピーター t は思います
自分が世界を変える桃
自分の世界を変えられることを説得的な仲間の集まり
つまり自分の信念に共感してくれたーー
人間が自分のチームいるようです
その後でパーカーやめるということは自分集価値観に共感できるんだっ
ということだからです
僕は
カラーテーマはせ
頭混乱しながらもまあ本当に彼に申し訳ないと思いました
というのも
岩船デー
お金で時間を買ってる存在だと僕は思っているんです
僕なんかがからの時間を食いつぶしていいわけがない
そう思っています
本当にお酒が入っています
なので僕は2つ彼に伝えました一つは坂本に相談する
もうたつわー
彼らの意思決定を尊重することです
まあ彼が止めてする美術
僕は本当にん
全てを投げ出したくなる腕面カードっていました
もう
新ソースとか言う言葉じゃ合わさない海の神を過ごしねっ
そしてもう
クローズさせをやってみましょうん
そこで僕はとりあえず坂本にこう言いました
もう
これは
祖母を率いていく新漏らしその1良くなりもう正直自分のやってることがあっているの
かどうかも分からない
だからもう1回辞めない
そう伝え1位
そうすると彼は僕にこう言ってくれたんです
これはこの価値観が
今は彼の開発を支援するだから突き進みしお肌と一緒に頑張ろう
僕はその言葉で感動というかこの言葉があったら
今回はっぽいないですね
その言葉のおかげで僕は最後ではリングこと
なんか3色おごりファイルを使っております
そこで僕がおったなぁ
育ていっぱいからは決断の手順でこういうものがあった
自分自身のたち彼に共感してくれる人が一人打ってとてもすごいと思う
簡単に1岡松感動させるて難しいことですよね
なんですけど自分自身のた後観に共感してくれる人か1人でも言ってすごいましたから
そういう人だけなら続ける価値はあるんじゃないん
つまり自分の子ですか家の畑に共感しない人が1人でもいいならやり続けると言って
決断をとっても間違いじゃない
そう思うようになりました
記憶など未来はとても言うなら観望して皆さんやと裏にクールです
宮止められた2つの景色からん
一つ目ばまあみんな知ってるとらんどまーくたぁ
コスモワールド凄い美しい景色が夜景が広がっている
もう一つは真っ暗で向上したいほとんどバックラージャンです
なんか戻ってこういう異名性があるなんですよ
ドローンにその事を解釈してとか
まだああ
中谷の明る人2月もあればくらい控除したい建立
そう思うようなわけです
だから僕はそんな中でもクラウドに言う時でも
中の示す価値の端さに共感してくれる人の一人でいいような
やり続けよう
思います
これが得だ今日伝えたかった自分の推しです
自分の示す8の端に共感してくれる人がいるからない
これが決断の基準ということです
以上ですありがとうございます
re た